We have a very backwards country in many ways. A
lot of you know that. We've seen that during the
last seven, eight months of the global pandemic.
We have a pandemic. And Donald Trump supporters
and right wingers go after the doctor telling us
how to fight the pandemic. Dr. Anthony Foushee
needing full time armed security.
Anthony found his daughter's needing security.
Well, now CBS has had to fire, hire rather full
time security for 60 Minutes correspondent Lesley
Stahl because trumpets are threatening her life
because she asked questions of Donald Trump
during the 60 Minutes interview that aired on
Sunday night. An unidentified suspect called
Leslie Stall's home on Thursday threatened her
family, said something about neo-Nazis. This is
a 78 year old reporter who did her job trying
to keep the president accountable, as we should
have the press doing in any viable democracy.
And she now needs security guards at her house.
The Trump ists, instead of seeing their dear
leader crumble under basic questioning and saying,
wow, maybe I shouldn't support Trump, they
instead go after the interviewer and she
now needs security at her house whenever she
goes out in public, because Trump supporters
are furious that she did an interview that wasn't
gushing praise like what Sean Hannity and Maria
Bartiromo and Rush Limbaugh and others do. Is
this what it means to win, to be so triggered
that you have to threaten a nearly 80 year old
woman for asking questions of the president? This
is what happens, though, when the president spends
more than a full presidential term attacking the
media, calling them fake and phony and the enemies
of the people. People start going after reporters.
The media, of course, are not infallible. The
media must be held accountable. Media get things
wrong and they should have to issue corrections
when they do. But this has gone too far. Guys,
Trump rose to power in this wave of nationalism
and anti press and anti free speech sentiment.
And these are the results. They've baked the cake.
Now they've got to eat it. And I hate to tell you,
Leslie Stall's interview wasn't even particularly
difficult. They were simple questions.
Mr. President, you said X defend it with
facts and Trump's not able to do it.
The fact that Trump can't answer doesn't mean that
the interview was in any way that much hardball
in other countries where elected officials are
frequently actually held accountable by the press.
That would not be considered a tough interview.
Just because Trump won't stop whining about it
doesn't mean it was actually tough. It just
means Trump can't handle it. Now, of course,
all right wing media, that is about law and order
and free spree speech, free speech and a free
press. I'm sure right wing media is denouncing
these threats against Leslie Stall, right?
Well, I searched I couldn't find anyone
saying a word about it in right wing media.
Don't know why. I wonder. We need change.
We need change. We have to remove this guy or
things are going to get even uglier. There is
no question whatsoever. And unfortunately, in
his removal, things may briefly get uglier. I've
been talking about that for a while. I am worried
about what Trumpet's may be capable of if their
dear leader is soundly defeated six days from
now. But it has to happen and understand that
the reason we're not going to hear criticism
of Lesley Stahl getting death threats
from the right and from Trump lists
is the same that we have people following these
evangelical televangelists, scammers and making
them multimillionaires. It will only end when
we break the cult of personality. The Michigan
governor had a kidnaping plot against her. Thanks
to Donald Trump directing his ire against her.
And Trump couldn't even flatly denounce the people
who planned the kidnaping of Gretchen Whitmer.
And meanwhile, just a final note
on the 60 Minutes interview,
Republicans and Trump ists have been slamming CBS
because they didn't air the full interview, which
60 Minutes never does. The way 60 60 Minutes is
a newsmagazine, they don't air uncut interviews.
They record an interview and they cut it to tell
a story. Along with images and whatever else,
the reality is, Trump looked better because 60
Minutes couldn't air Trump's entire interview.
The full interview, which Trump released on
Facebook. I think it was. Or maybe YouTube.
It makes him look worse, he said. Even crazier
things that see a CBS cut out in the 60 Minutes
interview. They didn't just edit the interview
so that it would fit on TV in the allowed time.
They edited it because Trump was making lunatic
unverified claims and not answering questions.
60 Minutes helped Trump by
editing down the interview.
What a backwards world we're living in right now.
We're going to have more on this on the David
Pakman show. Instagram page. David Pakman show.
You can also find me on Instagram.
Check out my latest tomato
haul from my urban garden
by following me on Instagram at David Pakman.